Biden's latest criminal Capers leaving
behind classified papers it's true
classified docs were found in an old
office by news before his campaign the
records are from his time as VP and
they're mostly posted saying please stop
talking love Barack
they returned over to the National
Archives on November 3rd before the
midterms but we're just hearing about it
now wow which makes sense because back
then we were all so focused on the start
of women's indoor track season
foreign
what are you laughing at meanwhile
Merrick Garland has assigned an attorney
to review the stuff which is good
because it's irresponsible to leave
classified stuff laying around I mean
how could that possibly happen
how that could possibly happen how one
anyone could be that irresponsible
and I thought what data was in there
that may compromise sources and methods
by that I mean names of people who
helped or Etc
and it just uh totally irresponsible
pot calling Kettle whatever
so will we see raids on Biden's homes
like we did with Trump will they go
through Jill's by Joe Biden's underwear
drawer it disclosed publicly that
they're all made of iron
they claim it was nuclear secrets and
then say it was memorabilia like an
autograph from the time he got to meet
Michelle
meanwhile the prez finally visited the
southern border for the first time
perhaps after hearing from his wife
about all the free breakfast tacos
at a Migrant Center he met members of
the Salvation Army but it sounds like he
mixed up one of them for Secret Service
watch
spend some time
seeing that makes me think he put the
CEO of Old Navy in charge of Afghanistan
well maybe it's got to be good but while
Joe was taking a trip to the Border he
was building a wall around one thing his
Delaware Beach House yep and why is that
well because walls work and they need to
keep out hunter's baby mamas
and sadly he's not getting Mexico to pay
for it the taxpayers will foot the 500
000 bill or one of his son's Finger
Paintings could do the trick what say
you Joe
no no no look look I I didn't mix up
that salvation guy with the Selective
Service like I know these guys and I
have respect for all our military I
don't care what branch you're in Arby's
rabies the airports to the machines look
and I I was out there with those guys I
was on the front lines with a Cirque du
Soleil and uh some of those guys didn't
come back
they're still up there on the
trapeze
[Music]
well
well done
cat you know basically I we don't really
care about documents everybody's got
documents but turn about it's like all
turnabout is fair play right I mean they
made it into such a big deal under Trump
that it was such a huge thing worse than
Watergate worse than everything he could
go to jail for treason so it's like they
kind of deserve whatever they get
no I guess but every all those stories
came out about how the Trump ones were
like how to do a bomb document which
there was never any proof or following
up on I didn't know that those were
documents that existed yeah I don't know
they could be nothing I I don't know but
I said the same thing about the Trump
stuff so I really don't know I haven't
seen them they won't let me
which is
yeah have you called them no they but
they don't call me I'm playing hard
again oh that's good that's good I don't
want them to know that I want to see
them yeah it's worked before it has it
has it has uh yeah I don't know I don't
think you're right though about the the
wall thing really because everyone keeps
assuming that it's just to keep you know
Joe safe from Intruders when really it
could just be to keep Joe from wandering
away
that could be helpful it's true it's
true there's there's a lot of freeways
near there you know what you want them
getting out on the interstate the same
thing with him forgetting what he's
saying or saying mixing up words it's
kind of a brilliant plan if it was the
plan because usually we hold presidents
accountable based on what they say with
Joe we're like yeah he just said stuff
again yeah exactly like when you go up
to a producer you go do you hear what
what Joe screwed up they'll go which one
yeah they're like I don't want to deal
with it Tyrus what do you think about
the wall okay the wall is irrelevant at
this point we need to put him in a life
preserver a bright orange that flashes
whenever he walks just so we know where
he's going
you you did poor sweet Joe a favor by
not showing the rest of that video
because as he talked to him about his
story of the Secret Service the poor
bastard goes he had to point to the guy
the shirt that said Salvation Army Goes
sir we're the Salvation Army and he's
like oh
so you're not a secret service like
what are we doing
he got the Salvation Army
confused with the Secret Service
I never thought I'd hear myself say this
Kamala you got to do something
who's making these decisions
he thinks the ice cream man's the
Secretary of State
what are we doing
and finally when he went to the Border
cat I'm surprised you didn't tear this
apart they made an Instagram horrible
relationship selfie of the Border they
cleaned it up for the picture and then
they took a nice picture of a nice
border with nobody there and then all
hell broke loose when they left like you
and your wife smile for the picture with
your happy life as soon as the camera's
gone you go to your separate bedrooms
yeah that's probably that's except when
he does it that's like that's propaganda
no it's true it's like well you know
when you when you throw a party when
your parents away and then you got to
clean it up before they get home you
know what I'm talking about right you
know in that picture he asked him what
time the elephant wakes up at the zoo
[Laughter]
[Applause]
these documents were found before the
elections and they come out now it seems
to be a pattern
it seems to be a pattern yes look
everything about this President and this
Administration is a joke it's an
absolute joke so this guy that was on a
visit to the Border by the way that was
a layover he was on his way to The
Summit in Mexico City so he had to
Simply have a layover in El Paso that
has more illegal immigrants streaming
across the border than it does a
population and like the Olympics in some
third world country they clean up the
streets before he comes because he can't
handle the truth and then beforehand
border patrol gets talking points from
this Administration instead of when
President Trump went to visit where he
said okay tell me tell me what is
happening here this guy from top to
bottom lives in a manufactured world and
he doesn't have the respect or the
dignity to afford the office he's
occupying the respect to read Governor
Abbott's letter or meet with border
patrol and then he messes up he confuses
thank you Secret Service Secret Service
I mean I am mortified I'm I am
disheartened by this and then yes the
classified documents the apologist media
comes in and says well it was just a
small amount and right away we gave it
to the National Archive so everything's
cool I mean the nuclear codes are what
one sentence long so it doesn't matter
the quantity it's the quality but I'm
really sick and tired of having this
President treated with these kid gloves
and the the media apologizing form every
second explaining everything away and a
silent impotent VP also they can both be
impotent yes because it's birthing
persons but I'm we have two more years
of this you guys we I we have to get a
republican in office I'm serious this is
to me it's like it's going from bad to
worse and I didn't think it could get
any worse than Rock Bottom with this guy
in charge wow yeah
ah strong words
strong words uh Jim you're obviously
everybody knows you as a political
historian yes you're working on a
three-volume book on the Biden family
yes I think it's called Biden times very
clever it is Biden times uh volume one
two and then I go to four and people
like where's three and I go aha
um he uh no those papers by the way I am
a historical uh uh whatever you call me
a man of historical means
um those papers were actually his
original handwritten notes from the
Louisiana Purchase really he did have uh
reason I'm probably the only big Pro
Biden guy here I think he's terrific
yeah um yeah it's an understandable
mistake the Salvation Army the secret
there's an s yes yes
and he might either meant that or senile
yes
he tried to put money in the guy's
holster
[Laughter]
and you know what the wall is for it's
because
summer house he has
it's a summer house for a president no
it's true it's kind of an embarrassing
little dumpy summer house yeah compared
to Obama's Martha's Vineyard home oh my
God you should see the basement
anyway yeah Biden just looks like a
screensaver yes wherever he walks he's
just like he's kind of should be in the
corner just kind of moping he is a
presidential screensaver he's just up
there until the work gets done and then
it goes away that's brilliant I'm
stealing that using it on the five of
course I'll have to kill you between
then so you don't call me on it I
shouldn't be talking about this on
television all right all right I'll
forget hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else